Major breaking news as the 11 judges
have just been selected to hear the
appeal in the Rode versus Bont case
dealing with whether or not California's
novel and insane ammunition background
check system is constitutional under the
second amendment. What is shocking about
the 11 judges that have just been
announced as the onbank panel for this
appeal is that eight eight of them
have been appointed to the federal bench
by a Republican president, three of them
by Democratic presidents. This is almost
unheard of in the context of an onbunk
review of a second amendment question in
the ninth circuit court of appeals out
of San Francisco to have a majority
Republican nominated set of judges. Now,
this doesn't guarantee the Second
Amendment is going to win, but it's at
least going to give the right to keep a
fighting chance in nutty California in
front of none other than the generally
terrible United States Court of Appeals
for the Ninth Circuit out of San
Francisco. Let's break down this big
developing news in the case of Rode
versus Bont and what it might mean for
all of our rights moving forward.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of Dina, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar
and I'm proud to say the top voice of
the Second Amendment in America. Thank
you 2025 and 2026 got these awards. All
right, folks. This is a big deal and
potentially very very good news. and
that is that the 11 judges who have just
been picked to hear the case
arising from California
involving California's law that says
that if you want to buy ammunition for a
firearm, you have to get a background
check. This is an outlier law. This is a
novel law specifically designed to
thwart the ability make it harder for
Americans in California to exercise
their right to keep and bear arms. It is
so extraordinarily insane that none
other than Harmy Dylan, the Second
Amendment unit at the Department of
Justice, has filed a brief in support of
the Second Amendment and against Rob
Bont in California, arguing that indeed
this California law, this background
check law is unconstitutional under the
Second Amendment.
Now the good news is that we in the
second amendment community won at the
federal trial court, the district court
that said indeed this law was
unconstitutional under the second
amendment. There was an appeal taken to
a three judge panel and in a two to1
decision the ninth circuit three judge
panel said yet again this California
ammunition background law was also
unconstitutional
two and 0 right two wins zero losses so
far when it comes to freedom and the
second amendment over this insane
California law so California did its
usual thing and they rode the die and of
course guess what they're trying to say
we want the US Court of Appeals for the
Ninth Circuit to hear this case and
overturn it like they always do in
second amendment cases. Whenever we win
in the second amendment issue in the
Ninth Circuit or down there in the
district courts, they always on bonk it
and overturn it because US court appeals
for the ninth circuit is generally
insane. Not everyone out there, not
every judge out there, but a lot of them
as you know. What a shocking and a
hugely positive development. Not
perfect, not a guarantee, but at least
hope. Something that is usually lacking
out there when it comes to Second
Amendment cases in the Ninth Circuit,
and that is hope. Hope for a Second
Amendment victory in an onbank panel.
Why do I say this? Because the 11 judges
picked to hear this case of Rode versus
Bont dealing with this ammunition
background check issue.
Of the 11 judges picked, believe it or
not, eight eight of them, eight out of
the 11 were actually picked by
Republican presidents.
Three were picked by Democrats. But I
should disclose that one of the judges
who was nominated by a president, Judge
Bby, uh actually ruled against the
second amendment in this very case of uh
of Rode uh he was in the descent in the
2:1 decision that said the majority said
of that 2:1 decision that this law was
unconstitutional, but Judge Bbeby said
that the law was constitutional and he
will be on the panel as one of the
Republican nominees. So that would
suggest that of the 11 judges um
potentially there could potentially be a
7 to4 victory. But again there are
Republican judges who are no good on the
second amendment to keep and bear arms
because a lot of them are law and order
types and think that whatever is good
for police, whatever is good for law and
order government is good for America.
And they don't care about the private
right to keep arms in the Second
Amendment. And they don't understand it,
nor do they try to do so. I'm not saying
that is the case with this particular
panel. But the good news is unlike
almost every other onbot panel that we
confront in the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals, we literally have a chance to
win. And that's not all, folks. There's
a bigger deal here. And what is that?
There's a rule out there. Listen
carefully.
The rule out there in the federal system
as to how it works is this.
An onbunk panel of a circuit has the
legal authority to overturn and undo the
decisions
of prior onbang and other panels.
So in theory,
if this Rode versus Bont
11 judge panel wanted to do so
and chose to do so,
they would actually have the generally
speaking authority to overturn Ninth
Circuit decisions previously decided on
the Second Amendment. Once they come
together, they can unwind precedents of
the Ninth Circuit against the Second
Amendment if they so choose to do so. Do
I think they're going to do it here?
Probably not. Do I think there's a good
chance that Kim Rood is going to win
this case and knock out the ammunition
background check system? Yeah, I think
there's a real chance here. Because we
must also remember
that none other than Harmy Dylan and the
second amendment unit of the Pam Bonnie
Donald Trump Department of Justice has
come to the rescue in this case. They
have filed a brief in this case arguing
that the three judge panel decision that
was 2 to1 in favor the second amendment
should be upheld and the California amu
ammunition background check system
should be tossed out. The Department of
Justice has filed a brief in this case
exactly arguing exactly that. As to
whether or not they'll get oral argument
time, I don't know. They might ask for
it. Harmy Dylan may fly out to
California to argue part of the case
herself, which would be great.
Nevertheless, this is a big deal, folks,
that we actually have a chance to win a
huge Second Amendment case in none other
than San Francisco's US Court of Appeals
for the Ninth Circuit. And just to jog
your memory about some of this, we've
covered this case before of Bonte of uh
Rode versus Bont. Uh we have to keep in
mind that when you're dealing with an
ammunition background check system, that
does implicate the plain text of the
Second Amendment. The plain text of the
Second Amendment says what? The right of
the people to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed. The right to keep
means the right to possess. The right to
bear means the right to carry guns in uh
in public for self-defense. And as we
know from that very famous and important
not US court of appeals for the seventh
circuit decision out of Chicago, the
Azel case, you also have the right to
train because how on earth are you able
to exercise your right to self-defense
with a firearm either in home or on the
road or on the street if you're not
proficient with firearms? If you don't
have familiarity with firearms, how do
you become proficient? and familiar with
anything. You got to practice. You got
to train
for guns with guns or anything else in
life for that matter. In fact, and
thanks to that ASEL president out of the
US Court Appeals for the Seventh Circuit
and the Supreme Court would agree with
that. Guess what that means? You have a
right to train. And by extension, what
do you need to train with a firearm?
Hello, McFly. Ammunition.
That's right. Not only do you need
ammunition for your firearm to protect
your home, you need ammunition to carry
in your gun in case of confrontation to
defend your life or the lives of others
if you're dealing with evil. You also
need ammunition to train, which is a
related plain text right. Again, the
right to keep and the right to bear arms
includes among other things, the right
to train, for example. And here because
you have a background check system
brought to us by the state of
California, a government actor that is
makes it extra. They're imposing a
hindrance, right? They're hindering your
ability to acquire ammunition by going
through this background check which cost
you money.
Now, of course, we know this is sort of
a pole tax, right? It's sort of a tax on
your ability to exercise your Second
Amendment rights among other things. But
more importantly, this is an outlier
novel law. As we've explained before,
there's a couple things the Supreme
Court does not like to see and will
often hammer it down
as an outlier, as something different,
as something weird when compared to the
rest of the country. Outlier laws that
infringe on the rights to keep and bear
arms, the right of other fundamental
rights for that matter. Here you have a
I believe the only one in the country
that I'm aware of
a fullblown background check to acquire
ammunition. That's an outlier thing.
Supreme Court doesn't like outlier
things. They'll smack that down. Second,
as we've talked about before, the US
Supreme Court is much more inclined to
knock out state gun laws than federal
gun control laws. That's why I never
liked John Sauer and the US Department
of Justice and the Solicitor General's
office pushing to the Supreme Court the
Hammani case to do with 922G and you
know being an unlawful user of marijuana
and possessing guns any more than I
wasn't happy about Joe Biden solister
general pushing to the Supreme Court the
Raheem case dealing with a you know an
admitted abuser of uh of girlfriends and
others domestic violence person admitted
so Um, I thought that those are bad
cases. Not only because of the bad
facts,
but because the Supreme Court as a
general matter is much more likely to
uphold laws enacted by Congress than
laws enacted by state legislatures. So
here in Rode versus Bont, you're dealing
with a California enacted law, which is
a state-based law, which the Supreme
Court is much more inclined to whack out
of the park. Get rid of it. Now, let's
just prove my point. Take a look at
Heler. What was Heler? Heler was a local
law by the District of Columbia. Got
smacked down. That was a handgun ban.
Got smacked down by Scoutus. What about
Breuan? That was a New York state law.
Could not carry gun without a license.
And you need to get a license. You had
to get blood, you know, permission,
discretionary permission from a
government actor. That was a state law.
Got smacked down by the Supreme Court.
Kitana was a Massachusetts law that said
you could not possess stun guns. got
smacked down by the Supreme Court in
Katano versus Massachusetts.
You see the trend here, folks? McDonald.
Guess what? McDonald was city of Chicago
law. Could not have a handgun in the
home. Otis McDonald, the plaintiff in
that case. Law got smacked down. Again,
another state-based law. Walford versus
Hawaii. Walford versus Lopez just got
argued. Hasn't been decided, but we're
going to win that case. Why? In part
because Hawaii went crazy again. Another
state law. Do you see the trend here,
folks? Do you see why I hammer home try
not to get involved with federal
challenges as a general matter to go to
Scotas? We're much more likely to win
these outlier laws brought to us by
nutty blue states and blue jurisdictions
than something that Congress passes.
That's the reality on the ground. And
here in the Rode versus Bont case with
the support of the Department of Justice
under Harmy Dylan obviously under Pam
Bondi and Donald Trump as well of course
uh they are fighting tooth and nail for
the second amendment against the state
of California. And given the fact that
we have an 8 to3 GOP uh nominated
majority in this onbunk court, there is
hope. I'm not saying it's a guarantee.
You got squishy squishy squishy
Republicans out there. We all know that.
especially on the gun issue. But at
least there's hope. And usually we don't
have hope. I should also just remind you
of one thing. In the rest of America,
when you're dealing with an onbunk
review for a US Court of Appeals, the
United States Court of Appeals for any
other circuit, the first circuit out of
Austin, the second circuit out of New
York, the third circuit out of
Pennsylvania, the fourth circuit out of
Virginia, whatever. When you deal with
an onbunk review, that is when every
judge that's active in that court
system, every circuit court judge that's
active, meaning they're not senior
status, they all sit on a big panel and
decide the case on bonk for the entire
circuit. But because the US court of
appeals for the ninth circuit based in
San Francisco is so large and has so
many judges, when the ninth circuit
takes a case on bonk, it is not. It is
not every active judge that hears the
case on bonk. It is select 11 out of
them hear the case on bonk. And there's
supposed to be some randomness
associated with this. And one wonders
whether or not that was true when judge
Reinhardt was on the Ninth Circuit. I'll
let you speculate about that as to how
he got on every onbank panel. That was
important, but again, that's a topic of
a different video. The bottom line is
the purportedly random draw of the
onbank 11 judges for the ninth circuit
in the road case has come up favorable
in that there's hope. And yes indeed,
for those of you wondering, Judge
Lawrence van Djk is indeed on that 11
judge panel. So, as to what that means,
let us keep our fingers crossed that
we're going to see a majority decision
out of the US Court of Appeals for the
Ninth Circuit written by Lawrence Van
Dyke just before potentially he's
elevated to the US Supreme Court. But
we'll talk about the candidates for a
potential Supreme Court vacancy in a
future video. and I'll give you the list
and the good and the bad and the ugly of
each of them and the statistical odds of
them filling a vacancy should one become
available this summer or otherwise. Okay
folks, so fingers crossed candles lit
for Rode versus Bont. Uh the argument is
going to be on March 25th. So it's
coming up in about I don't know you know
10 days or so and we will certainly
cover that when the argument occurs. And
without further ado I again I thank you
all for tuning in to the four box of
Diner. We now have over 76 million views
on this channel and over 250,000
subscribers. So, I thank you all for
making this super nerdy uh geeky channel
uh a success. And again, I cannot thank
you enough for helping out here. We
really appreciate uh uh your support.
And again, thanks again. Make sure you
follow me on x forbox. Don't forget to
subscribe both the YouTube and the
rumble. And I'll talk to all of you
again real soon here at the four boxes
diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2 A.